[Music]
the skip recap button that's right i'm
sending the amazon interface for
allowing me to skip a part of the show
that i've previously sinned sure it
looks all sexy and convenient but it
offloads the administration of this
experience onto me this is essentially
the digital equivalent of the
self-checkout lane at the supermarket
stop trying to automate perfectly good
jobs plus my hands are currently
occupied with stuffing artificially
flavored cheesy popcorn into my face and
i'll not risk the sanctity and
cleanliness of my remote by handling it
while my hands are covered in what feels
like a mixture of elmer's glue and
climbing chalk do we have to see the
immortals decapitation every damn time
and why am i still trying to eat taco
bell while watching this show i might
have a problem joe has bryant mumble
step on this scorpion throw a cigarette
at this guy and push past this crowd
instead of just giving him an apple to
prove how much of an [ __ ] he is now i
have to give this three sins instead of
one also murder discount jon hamm only
one snap and no shake that's just
blatant disregard to the established
glow stick activation procedure there is
no way it would be this luminous
what did discounts that ippo think
discount indiana jones was up to nothing
good comes from opening mummy tombs
there's an insane amount of examples in
other shows and movies you could have
done some [ __ ] research is all i'm
saying my first thought was that this
door fell into place by sheer luck my
second thought was that one of these
guys just happened to be proactive
enough to shut the door on this
nightmare my third thought was that
omniman threw this door into place as he
and invincible were flying by finally my
fourth thought was giving this moment a
sin because i'm pretty sure five
thoughts would have caused the nexus
event and frankly i don't have time for
that messing up the desert
huh
[Laughter]
jk simmons man jk [ __ ] simmons what
happened to gain some altitude messing
up the desert closer to the surface now
than invincible was when he was kicking
up the sandstorms wait where's mount
everest
it's the high one dad directions hey
deep breaths buddy the air's been up
here show's already established that
invincible's lungs are too strong for
this to make any sense in episode two
held his breath during a lengthy flight
in space then a conversation in space
and then took time to stop and enjoy the
view from space why would breathing be a
concern here sometimes i forget how
beautiful this planet can be too bad the
human race is hell bent on destroying it
look if i wanted captain planet i'd
watch well
captain planet this login screen has no
forgot password link considering how
much effort went into writing these
articles in episode two i was really
surprised that the show went with this
lorem ipsum nonsense but judging by the
glowing circle forming in my living room
reading that latin text aloud may have
been a bad choice i'll deal with that
later
amber mark appear to be traveling in the
same direction despite the fact that
mark's legs are clearly angled at least
45 degrees to the direction of travel
they're called balls throwing a hard b
on your balls slow hanging fruit maybe
you came to finish the job you started
with the guardians you're the demon
after all that's demonist if you
threaten my family again cliche
run the jewels are not soundtracking my
daily activities in this scene this very
sophisticated device used to make clones
runs on frozen hamburgers we're cool
right don't know don't care skip
alienating adam eve was the direct
result of your lapse in judgment do not
repeat it with monster girl since the
show's been pretty well written so far
i'll presume this whole scene is a setup
for something that being said this is
gross and even though rex even explains
why it's gross what are you crazy man
she looks like she's 14. that doesn't
make the choice to put it in the show
any less gross now that i'm a guardian i
can bang anyone i want using your
position in the corporate ladder to gain
sexual advantages i like dealing with
work stuff yeah and i love that about
you don't give me that marriage mark is
not trying at all to conceal that secret
identity which makes this conversation
later with eve about telling amber who
he is all the more odd what if amber had
forgotten to tell mark something or open
the door right here or a neighbor was
out walking their dog i don't like mark
missing school this is debbie's worry
that mark will miss school not that
he'll be going to a planet humans have
never set foot on or that he'll be in
space for the next two weeks where just
about anything could happen but yeah
missing an english exam real bummer sure
but it's not like dating rex worked out
mark survives this you help me with my
amber stuff
i'll help you with your wreck stuff how
exactly would mark help eve with her rex
stuff can you go back in time to stop
rex from being a cheating [ __ ] i
don't think he can i figured you need
something that's a nice gesture for mark
but where did he get the 800 that turned
him off from buying the ball in the
first place i'm i'm going away and
helping people this works first off just
look how [ __ ] cool this space shuttle
is second look at how aerodynamically
unsound these rocket boosters are i may
not have the time or education to
properly calculate drag coefficients but
i assume rectangular cuboids have either
lots of drags or lots of coefficients
wrong i'm a ghost even as a ghost the
people inside can probably hear you tap
dancing across the outside of their ship
there are martians what do you think
martian man came from jupiter cecil
would be invincible at tv sins martians
way to bear the lead cecil actually the
lead is
make sure our astronauts get home safe
technically cecil still buried the lead
he didn't mention this till after the
martian talk i know you're all tired of
me preaching about kessler syndrome but
when you're done playing with your
villains you can't just leave them
floating in orbit it's a disaster
waiting to happen as i noted earlier
mark has already been to space once but
didn't take note of the temperature or
think that maybe sandwiches don't work
in the vacuum of space they land the
ship for a second and hop straight the
[ __ ] out this is mars not a rest stop
don't you have to check with fido first
or some
this extra is staring right at the
camera
do you trust me debbie considering the
convenience of this dragon popping up
literally right behind them while
they're in another country if i were
debbie i'd be thinking nolan set these
shenanigans up so the answer is no
debbie it's [ __ ] no i don't trust you
nolan
i guess the good thing for dark blood is
no one will ever ask him to be on plant
watering duty while they're out of town
other humans in white are they like you
aliens conveniently speak english cliche
alone their group mind is scattered and
weak but with an appropriate host they
become unified and unstoppable snyder
bros how exactly is mark protecting the
astronauts he's giving them zero cover
he should at least be running behind
them ah oh hey you're
back early invincible doesn't even need
his key to open this door which is
surprising when you consider how
paranoid nolan was when cecil showed up
earlier but more importantly nolan and
debbie deserve a sin for going to pound
town with the front door unlocked when
you know you have a teenage son who you
just come home at any moment but more
importantly the last time we saw these
two nolan pretty much refused to save
people from a fire-breathing dragon and
apparently debbie was super turned on by
this this is a sin because i used to
like you debbie see that's the problem
with demons you only see good and evil
black and white no the problem with
demons is they never pick up their toys
oh wait that's kids same difference
finally
phase one begins but what the [ __ ]
happened to the mummy from the beginning
of the episode
now this is the plan
get your ass to moss
for the last time
join me
or die
don't you dare shush me just know i have
a whole bag of shh
with your name on it that was the best
night of my life i'm about to eat nachos
it's the greatest moment of my life
calculating landing ellipse based on our
last uncorrupted nav state i'd say we're
somewhere in this 60 by 120 kilometer
ellipse we just got to close in on the
downrange variables
it's about the math
this is it
that moment they told us about in high
school where one day algebra would save
our lives don't open that it's an alien
planet is there air you don't know
what is your purpose here nobody exists
on purpose nobody belongs anywhere
everybody's gonna die
blow the bomb harry we're with you guess
what donald found when we searched your
office
tiny pies
say i'd see you in hell we have such
sights to show you